so far we looked at open end mutual
funds that can kind of grow and shrink
depending on how many investors want to
invest in that fund they can grow by
creating new shares and selling those
shares to the general public and they
can shrink because someone who wants
their money back goes to the fund and
says
you have to buy this back from me at the
nav at the net asset value per share but
the problem with it actually there's a
couple of problems is that the manager
here has to always keep a little cash
set aside in case some of the investors
come to him and say hey i want you to
buy my share back i want liquidity and
the other thing that they have to worry
about or at least from the investors
point of view is
they can only buy or sell at the end of
the day and that will only happen at the
net asset value per share and on top of
that the fund manager or whoever's
running the fund has to worry about all
of these and actually transacting
between all of these different investors
now on the other side of things we
looked at the closed end fund the
closed-end fund couldn't kind of
dynamically grow and shrink by creating
new shares or by buying them back but
what was good about them is is that they
were freely trading on exchanges maybe
on the on the nasdaq or the new york
stock exchange and because there was
none of this kind of back and forth
between the fund managers or whoever was
man whoever was kind of doing the the
operations of the fund and the investors
they didn't have to put cash aside and
they didn't have to have all of this
kind of overhead in dealing with the
investors now you're probably saying
well isn't there a way or maybe there's
a way to get the best of both worlds a
fund that could grow dynamically that
could create new shares when there was
demand from investors but at the same
time those new shares could be traded on
an open market and that combination or
you can kind of view it as the
combination of the two actually exists
and they're called exchange traded funds
exchange
exchange traded
funds or
etfs for short and you might say hey
wait isn't a closed end fund exchange
traded and it is these these actually do
trade hands on on the stock exchanges
but these aren't officially etfs when
someone tells you an etf the way to
think about it it's a combination of
both but what it does is
it limits the interaction so when you
have just a regular open end mutual fund
any individual investor can come to the
fund and say here's my share buy it back
from me eliminate that share and that
creates a lot of overhead here on an
exchange traded fund only approved
people only and these are usually large
institutions can go to the fund and say
i want to buy or redeem a big block of
shares so an exchange traded fund
instead of creating one share at a time
it might create five thousand or ten
thousand or a hundred thousand shares at
a time and on the other side of things
if someone wanted to redeem their shares
they would redeem five thousand ten
thousand or a hundred thousand shares at
the same time and what's good there from
the funds point of view is that they
don't have to deal with all of these
small transactions they can do big
transactions with big entities so that
saves them costs on overhead
and since these big people go and
kind of buy these big blocks of shares
they can go and sell them in the open
market they could trade them in the open
market so if you want to buy and buy
into an etf instead of buying it
directly from the the etf you would buy
it from one of these big institutions
that by big blocks of shares so they're
now buying you know a big block of you
know maybe this is 10 000 shares right
over here and then they will trade in
the open market so you get you kind of
get the best of both worlds and in
general etfs also have lower fees and
they have lower fees one because they
don't have to do all this back and forth
between each individual investor and
most etfs are not actively managed when
i say actively manage i'm talking about
the situation where you had pete and
pete says that he's just an awesome
stock picker he can beat the market he
can you know do all of you know he
really researches companies and he
thinks that there's some value that he
creates by doing that when something is
not actively managed and exchange trade
funds tend to not be they're saying look
we're just going to buy the market or
we're just going to buy some commodity
so when you go into an exchange traded
fund you're really just trying to buy
some asset class maybe it's the s p 500
maybe you are maybe some type of
exchange trade funds that buys gold as
assets or maybe it's buying some other
type of commodity and so because it's
not actively managed the argument would
be that they don't need as much in
management fees so they will have lower
fees
they will have lower fees so it's a
combination they can grow arbitrarily
large and some of the largest exchange
exchange trade funds are super huge they
have much lower fees and they have this
trade ability you can trade them at any
kind of second on the markets you don't
have to wait until the end of the day
like an open end fund